hey guys it is Friday so here's your top
five stories of the whole gaming wink
and when I'm gonna be talking about PD
pie because I think we have better
things to talk about so here's your
PewDiePie free wrap this up a retailer
has slipped up and sent a min tender
switch out to somebody two weeks early
not great for them but good for us
here's what we found out near gap use a
hip hop the robot kudos on the username
published a video of them using the
Nintendo switch showing the initial
setup process as well as its main menu
and settings the video indicates that
the system has 25.9 gigabytes of free
space out of the box and that can be
expanded further with micro SDXC cards
up to two terabytes in size which
officially launches worldwide on march
three a massive battlefield one update
was released to this week and here's the
skinny on what Smith dice released to
the two gigabyte winter update across
ps4 xbox one and pc on valentine's day
the update sees the return of ribbons as
well as they jump in the maximum class
rank from 10 to 50 you will now earn
battle packs for every ten class ranks
you gain as well as some extra Flair
when you hit rank 50 elite courtesies
have been added for the eight primary
weapons that are unlocked by obtaining
500 more kills per applicable weapon for
your efforts you will receive a shiny
new codex and 25,000 XP so get out there
and start mowing down foes server
improvements include the ability for RSP
admins to kick players from their
servers from the in-game UI as well as
being able to ban problematic players
play it's going to also vote for the
next map after a match is over there
have also been a bunch of improvements
to vehicles you I maps weapons
spectating custom game modes gameplay
controls and net code for all the
intricate details check out our full
story on games but this week Nintendo
revealed that the legend of zelda breath
of the wild will have a DLC pass and
who's worth coming with that the twenty
dollar expansion pass kicks off by
offering you an instant bonus when the
game launches
on March 33 treasure chests will
materialize in the great plateau which
contain useful items as well as an
exclusive immersion breaking shirt
featuring a Nintendo switch logo that
you can put on link the first DLC pack
arrives this summer and consists of the
cave of trials a hard mode and an
additional map feature the second DLC
pack which will release in this year's
holiday season enjoyed the new original
story and a new dungeon the DLC packs
won't be sold separately but they will
arrive for both Wii U and switch strap
in for the most exciting news since
Activision said that there's going to be
another call of duty game this year
another Pokemon go update has arrived
the latest update brings with it to
quality of life changes including
letting you access your different
pokeballs and berries from the encounter
screen no more digging through the items
list to get to the things you need
there's also new music for you to enjoy
during encounters at night another small
change shows you a silhouette of the
creature you'll obtain if you opt to
evolve the one you have the update adds
over 80 additional Pokemon from the gold
and silver games and gender specific
variations of select Pokemon can be
caught niantic have also said trading
and player versus player battles are on
the way soon finally in devastating news
the thimble is no longer a monopoly
piece my personal favorite piece after
the dog obviously didn't make the cut on
a fan vote that took place over the last
month hasbro invited fans to vote on the
eight pieces that should be included in
future monopoly editions and as a result
the most fun piece to hold because of
all the dimple bits has been voted off
the board it's the weakest link it did
not receive a rose it will have to leave
the mansion hasbro said despite being an
integral part of day-to-day life when
the token was originally added to the
game in 1935 the lucky symbol has lost
its shine with today's fans and will be
retired from the game Hasbro will be
revealing the results of the fan vote on
world monopoly day on March 19 at least
the dog will probably still be in it
this week on site we take a look at the
first 12 minutes of prey explore some of
the most bizarre dating Sims out there
and review Sniper Elite Four that is it
for me this week be sure to have
yourselves a lovely weekend give us a
like on YouTube if you like because we
like you and I will see you again on
Monday
[Music]